curtain race it goes up and it stops at
their belly and what do you think is
showing
full badge
everything but you don't see their faces
or they're being it's not blurred out
even a little bit so he's looking at the
four options
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters sophie and
sistine stallone so steen is not here
today though where is she
she decided to stay home i'm filling in
guy fieri hello everybody thank you for
having me on you guys we replaced the
steam with guy fieri
welcome to flavortown baby i'm very
excited to be here yeah me too i know
sophia's out of town too football player
as you can see by the one chartsy let me
just explain before my mustache peels
off if you guys are watching the video
format of this podcast
it is halloween week sophia and i
thought we had to take the opportunity
to dress up for halloween now i give
myself an a minus in costume i decided
to go as guy fieri
i feel it i feel good my mustache you
look at it your hair looks great
it's
you look like a porcupine i think you're
gonna say a porn star
how do you like a porn star in any
remote way i got the porn star stash um
fair fair sofia i'd give you a c minus
on effort today with your outfit
well okay i think my outfit from what i
was intentionally trying to do is a c
minus but now what i think it actually
is i think it's an a plus okay now i
think i'm a jersey chaser
fitting right
i think
that's the mustache is falling off
wait is that the steam
no
i have to take it off oh my gosh we'll
put them on the skeleton i don't know so
i i had this idea of what i wanted to do
i thought i had shoulder pads and all
this stuff and then ended up working out
then i decided to put hoops on and i
thought okay now i look way more like a
girl that was invited to a football game
you know what it's okay there are two
types of girls on halloween those who
go crazy scary put an effort and those
who just
want to be sexy nothing wrong with that
you tell who's who
um no but i'm really excited about this
week i feel like i've done a pretty good
job of getting into the halloween spirit
i've been watching a lot of scary shows
scary movies no one wants to watch them
with me you know i no one in the house
likes scary movies except i hate it
though because whenever people go oh my
god i hate scary i won't go you know to
universal
halloween i didn't do the whole thing
and
they always look at me like a crazy
person for liking yeah scary film well i
would choose um having a better night's
sleep than being traumatized for the
next week thinking that there's
something under my bed well i could
still sleep i don't know how
absolutely don't know how i'm not into
anything popping up i don't know if you
guys are feeling like me i don't like
gore bloody things i don't like
chainsaws my biggest fear are clowns
clowns are just not it i will actually i
was going to be a clown this year
i
i would have been so mad that's like me
i can't dress up as your fear she has
philosophia can't dress up like a body
of water
but i i just i don't know i don't like
things jumping out and giving me well
it's not really a heart attack well
that's kind of why i like it though and
i know that sounds crazy but i watch a
rom-com and i don't cry i watch a comedy
and i don't laugh but when i watch a
horror film
yeah i'm scared but i feel something and
i think that's exciting when a movie
makes you yeah uncomfortable i'm i'm
more with scary i would say thriller
suspense kind of like taken ish but
anything okay i i wait you know what
it's weird i like realistic horror
things which is probably worse than uh
demonic
type i know
yeah it gets [ __ ] up to say i have a
favorite serial killer like i shouldn't
say that she does but i do she does
she's not glorifying that i just want to
make sure i know i'm not
she's not but i don't yeah i don't like
scary supernatural
no anything i don't either i'm i'm
really excited for this halloween
because we've been repressed for two
years and we have been talking about it
since the last halloween about our
expectation i know in the last episode
we were kind of going off talking about
how we every year ago something funny we
were gonna do mr 305 this year
didn't get it together maybe we have we
have a week or a couple days when this
episode comes out i don't know why i'm
just lazy i'm so much lazier i know i
feel like i'm lazy with everything i
woke up at 5 a.m stressed stressed
stressed about halloween actually i was
trying to talk to her in the car and she
said i'm tired stop talking to me and so
i said
okay i'll stop
that is that how we're going to rewrite
it that's how it was in my head
see that's your problem
i'll say something not that dramatic and
then you'll rewrite history and be like
well you said you cannot deny i was
being so nice and you were giving me
zero zero effort and you're like i told
you i'm tired i'm like okay
boo hoo i will wake you up at four every
day why i don't know
honestly it's so weird i thought it was
jet lag from leaving and now tungsten
we're in london but i've been waking up
every day two am and then i get pissed
and then i wake up at four and then i
really can't get back to sleep so i'm up
i'm watching what was it what i've been
watching you on netflix i've been
reading a lot squid games i've been
walking back and forth to my room
because they say that to like fall back
asleep you got to get out of your space
and so i just oh my god i was i thought
the footsteps were above me those are
yours yes they were me
never me i've been just walking around
my world too though keeps me up the
people that live above us above my room
fight
all the time really sophia i hear them
screaming it's a guy and a girl
screaming all the time this is like the
build-up to a new halloween horror movie
you know like the woman in the window
but no we're not we're gonna i feel like
boy we will do mr 305 but we did do the
lonely island justin timberlake did
comment on that and i'll never forget it
in my life i want to repost that video
and maybe show you guys so you guys get
a little pretty iconic it was pretty
iconic you wanted to do which i'm
assuming every person's gonna do this
year for halloween is the squid games
yeah every person's gonna be that it's
the easiest thing you just wear a
jumpsuit i'm gonna give my opinion on it
probably an unpopular one all right here
we go
i don't get the hype
i
i don't get it how do you not get the
hype it's one of the coolest shows
i understand why it's cool maybe i'm
just not
focusing i don't you aren't focused i
feel like people
are really blowing it up and by the way
it deserves it because it is a really
cool show but it's how do you not think
it's so genius like all the little games
you don't i don't even think you
understand the plot twists that are
happening while you're watching you know
what i think it is you know when
um
i guess i guess society we'll call it um
hypes up one thing
so much to the point that you're like oh
my god i used to like it and now i don't
like it anymore because it's so
mainstream now everyone likes it yeah
that's how i feel about you i don't like
it like olivia rodrigo when the driver's
license came out i was like this is the
i still think i love all her songs and
we were like this is the greatest song
ever and then it just blew up and now i
can and i was listening to it exactly
i'm like who hurt you
she's 17. i'm like who hurt you
yeah can you why don't you explain it
well i know i'm not defeating the per i
think she's a very very talented person
nothing against her but i was just
thinking
how does this girl who's 17 years old
have this much intense heartbreak
at such a young age like i i mean was it
that one guy i guess we're just jealous
because we've never been in love to that
level we've never been pop stars and
that's been my dream forever i know
sofia you do i'm just jealous of you
olivia pop star for halloween i already
i am a pop star for halloween
i'm a spice girl
oh yeah i'm ginger spice yes i'm wearing
the iconic london flag i'm gonna dye
your hair red yeah i'm dying my hair
right i'm kind of worried that it's
gonna end up staining blonde let's talk
about where we just were we were just in
london with um sly and jennifer our
parents yeah and uh
i love them but to say the least i'm
really happy to be back i didn't have
fun
you want to know what we did well i
thought this is this is our problem
we go to a sick place like london yeah
we should have planned fun restaurants
planned activities
i wanted to go on a haunted ghost tour
no one wanted to join you have to admit
it was a little sketch there's a bus
that says hana uh taurus and there's one
guy in there that looks like he's been
sleeping in there for the past 12 years
alone
so that's character yeah it's a part of
the halloween spirit it was frustrating
because our family as a whole is so lazy
yeah so we don't book dinners we didn't
book anything so every single day we
just sat in the hotel yeah this is our
routine we'd wake up
work out for two hours because we don't
know what else to do walk around
get coffee all we did was eat though all
we did was eat and not good food no pub
food all day every day but sophia and i
were walking and we're just you know
going for a stroll trying to kill time
and i see on a giant billboard
magic mike
magic mike live in london and i said
hey sophia check this out as a joke as a
joke and we're walking past the
billboards and each billboard's a
different guy shirtless and i go you
know and i was like what did
we go inside it wouldn't hurt to just
check check it out
like it's 12 in the afternoon let's just
like see what's going on so we did
sprint in there hoping no one else would
no we we
were literally gonna say
verbatim we were those girls slowly
backing up into the doorway making sure
because we went to a magic mic at noon
us us so we go to the uh the checkout
guy or the ticket guy and we say sir
when's the next show he goes there's one
tonight i go i kept giving him
hypotheticals we're like hypothetically
if we were to choose this seat what's
the odds of us getting a lap dance
exactly what time should we go like we
just
nobody we would always even say like if
we were up here
do they dance near us or if we were over
here
would they be
so if you guys are picking up what we're
putting down
we did get tickets and we went honestly
completely sober completely sober and we
chose the second row because we were
like you know what we get a better view
of the stage down there we're like
there's no way these guys are gonna like
come up to us i had a blast i think you
were a little bit uncomfortable the
entire time he wasn't cecina you were
you were like not you were like oh uh
so false that is so false how about when
the guy came up to you and said yeah
that's not that's not uncomfortable that
was me
okay you guys let me just explain
something this doesn't ever happen to me
i've never had this happen before in my
life
so these guys are dancing whatever and
they actually end up dancing on the
railing
where we were sitting so basically we
were kind of getting a front row show
anyways um
i remember
[Laughter]
okay so i remember in the beginning of
the show there was one guy i noticed
down there i'm like oh he's super cute
like he is my type on paper and you know
oh also i was looking for everyone on
love island didn't find anybody maybe
your accent scared them away yeah i
tried i did try um fit bud um
okay so there was one guy on the ground
that i was just like this is it he's so
cute it was so funny because he was just
not my type even a little no you thought
there was like another one that you
thought
i just noticed you put a mustache on the
skeleton um so
surprisingly an hour into the show he
ends up being the one to stand on the
platform in front of us like directly in
front of us but he was waiting for his
queue to start dancing so he's kind of
just standing there um and he's directly
in front of us
you're not explaining it right yeah i am
let me give some pov to the listeners
we're sitting this guy is standing on a
balcony
towering directly in front of sophia so
basically his kneecaps are where her
eyeline is so she's looking straight up
at this guy and he's looking straight
down at her and i'm on the side like
so he first and i
he's beautiful and then he's up close
and i'm like speechless he asks me he in
a of course british accent like how are
you
no he goes you're right you're right
and i go no
she said nothing i said nothing i kept
going
up so then i've never done that in my
entire life no no when i say she was
speechless it was almost like her mouth
was open and breath was coming out but
no words were coming out
and i'm sitting on the side like sophia
i think he literally reiterates because
you know he goes are you all right
michael
yeah i don't know i was like
yeah
how are you are you good and yeah he
literally just looked at you like he's
like
sure yeah i'm fine so then his cue comes
on he's dancing and then decides because
he knows that i'm the one that's like
flabbergasted and just like
total like lust he grabs my face oh my
god this is when it gets good
this is when it gets good so i'm sitting
on the side my my head is like watching
a tennis match i'm going back i just
feel this electricity or maybe no it was
just maybe me being like maybe hold on
we're saying like he's flirting with you
like at this job he wasn't
at all i was like see we got a
connection i was like sophia you're the
main character no he's a stripper of
course he's so slow with you jesus so
he grabs sophia's chin and like pulls it
up to his face and i'm still sitting on
the side like
can a girl get some but i was excited
for you yeah and sophia literally left
so happy i looked like chester the cat
you she was i've never seen you grin so
hard and so aggressively it was like
your cheeks were stiff it was i i've and
it's you guys i don't know if you've
ever felt like you've ever seen someone
and been breath away like i he was so he
was like pretty but i was like
undressing you with the eyes he had
those eyes he had those eyes yeah he
knew exactly what he was doing and he
knew exactly who this target was
and it worked and he chose it right it
worked but it was funny also because our
mom was texting us going where are you
because we weren't texting her we
weren't calling her we didn't let her
know where we were and they said we're
at the london theater yeah they're so
they go you guys should kill time go see
some good london shows and so i sent her
a video of where we were and she's like
what the actual hell so that was
probably my favorite um but
you think that was the craziest part of
our weekend
why don't we talk about
what channel we stumbled upon at like 2
a.m in london the british tv is the best
if this tv show was in the us it would
be the number one show also probably
canceled probably the number one show
and probably the most cancelled show in
the world it is genius and i love that
there's i think it's so funny it's kind
of weird
what is it called naked attraction naked
attraction so you already know
here it goes
so my parents were
this is the fact that our mom told me
she said foundation
we get a text in the group chat at 11 30
at night saying channel 52 winky face
and i was like mom what turn it on and
she goes i thought it was the show naked
and afraid yeah that's really popular
because she saw naked attraction so she
thought oh naked and afraid nope
nope nope nope so let me just explain
the scenario
there are
hazy walls covering four
contestants right so it's almost like
you can't see through the window but you
see a figure it's like these four people
standing in tubes and tubes yeah and you
can't see them and one guy in the middle
with the host
and he's talking about his type and he
what kind of girl he likes
suddenly
basically what kind of girl basically
suddenly the girl goes okay
let's reveal
the first part
then when i say the tube starts slowly
going and starts pulling up and it stops
and you see just feet and then you see
calves and then you see knees and then
you see
upper thighs and you're like oh oh okay
and then the guy looks at the four girls
and goes
all right um
this one right here eliminated don't
like her thighs
oh oh oh and then she leaves right she
leaves and then it goes round two
curtains it goes up and it stops at
their belly and what do you think is
showing
full badge
everything but you don't see their faces
or their brains it's not blurred out
even a little bit so he's looking at the
four options
out get out of here i don't like it and
then it raises raises and you see just
their boobs and just rolls their neck
now yeah so now it's like you just see
bodies no heads at this point yeah
it is and he's so so
really talking he goes you know i really
like a like a full handful but i really
like like this like this girl's a nipple
piercing i really like like the color of
this one it is insane so he eliminates
them by the way when they're eliminated
you think they just go away and their
faces aren't seen no they come out their
faces they come out they're like look
what you missed and they went
away naked so then the final part is
my favorite one so the final two the the
the faces raised so now you see these
two girls ass naked ass naked with the
contestant and the host
and
the girls come out and you think okay
that's sexist why are there girls just
standing naked and a guy gets to pick
them apart oh no no oh no no the guy
goes in the back he gets fully naked
he walks out and the girl judges a girl
judges him and decides if if that's
enough for her
and
and look one of the girls will say yes
and one of the girls will basically say
no so absolutely not and then the show
progresses so then he passed the fact
that they hug like the two naked bodies
just so crazy then you see them go on
their first date close and yeah clothed
and um it's just so funny i have never
seen a show like this but i love it that
so you'll have one episode of all female
contestants yeah and then you'll have
the next one six guys six guys and one
girl i mean it's so great imagine that
in the u.s would that ever
no i mean it is what channel did we see
and this is not like a nice hotel i'm
like what type of channels do we have
going on here but um naked attraction so
you guys want to look it up that's
awesome speaking of
bush should we talk about our first
sponsor that's a good idea so we will be
right back
[Music]
attention to all men across the galaxy
the universe
the planets
all the way to australia to houston
do you have a pew problem
if so it's okay it's okay our friends at
manscape have cleared you for takeoff
and their fourth generation and brand
new
lawnmower
4.0 baby
yes the lawnmower 4.0 is included in the
performance package 4.0 the orbits in
your pants you guys will feel like
there's zero gravity when you use the
best tools for the job from the leaders
in male grooming and on groomed man is
literally not a pretty sight there's
nothing that turns us off more when a
guy's ungroomed let me tell you no one
wants a friction burn ladies you know
what i'm talking about all right so
thank you for sharing to help men get
out of this world experience look no
further than the performance package 4.0
from manscaped that has just taken off
not only in the usa but canada the uk
europe australia south africa and
singapore if these names aren't
hilarious enough inside this package
you'll find their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
this is a great name weed whacker ear
and nose hair trimmer a crop
preserver ball deodorant
a crop reviver toner performance boxer
briefs and a travel bag to hold
his whole solar system
you know i want to get me some of that
ball deodorant i don't know what i would
need it for but it seems important so
first scheduled for liftoff new
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer this spaceship is
here to guide your man on a journey to
trim your body balls butt and even your
anus babies
this fourth generation trimmer features
a cutting edge ceramic blade to reduce
grooming accidents thanks to their
advanced safe skin technology no one
wants
little nicks down there let me tell you
it doesn't feel good so the lawnmower
4.0 has a 7 000 rpm motor jesus that's
fancy and a new multi-function on off
switch that can engage a travel lock and
is even waterproof the performance
package also includes what i love called
the weed whacker it's like a little
astronaut for men to chop their worst
weeds on top of their noses and ears no
one likes hair sticking out of their
nose and ears people the weed whacker is
waterproof and uses 9000 rpm moto power
360 rotary dual blade system their nose
and ear hair trimmer provides propriety
skin safe technology which helps prevent
nicks snacks and tugs in those delicate
holes men make sure you use the crop
preserver ball deodorant all right we
all know i'm a fan of it already and
their crop reviver to help these little
planets beyond their a-game while
feeling the sun's heat better yet
manscaped are you ready for this even
threw in two not one
two free gifts to their performance
package 4.0 the manscaped boxers and the
shed travel bag you guys just join the
two million
men worldwide who trust manscape and get
your rocket ready to take off by going
to manscapes.com for 20 off plus free
shipping with the code unwaxed that is u
n w a x e d that's twenty percent off
plus free shipping with the code unwaxed
at manscaped.com
your spaceballs will thank you
i haven't done a conspiracy on this
podcast in a very long time and it hurts
my soul i'm not gonna lie it hurts our
souls cause that was something that we
really wanted to dedicate to and i was
passionate about it i know i mean some
of our best ones lizard people
that was another one
lizard people chuck e cheese
chuck e cheese the one with elsa and um
walt disney being frozen
true yeah i remember that one very good
thank you honey water dasani water has a
little bit of what was it salt salt and
and um i thought you said cocaine
cocaine was it what was it like
magnesium sulfate yeah did i make that
up no it was it was but it was like i
think it was a drug
it's the third lethal injection used to
kill yes inmates so it's not cocaine
there's no cocaine and josani don't
assume jesus definition of character
okay
so i decided to bring in
two
halloween conspiracies you guys are in
for a treat one of them i found on
reddit which uh is very suspicious
already
and i think it might be really dumb but
i'm gonna read it anyway okay here we go
are you ready
so excited hello all and welcome
today i'll be presenting everyone with
an interesting and scary conspiracy
theory now today's topic is fun event of
halloween my theory is that halloween
was made by the government or illuminati
you know i love illuminati
to weaken the immune system of the young
generation of children and make them
more vulnerable to the leaders of the
world wait
they may make us do things to control us
and make
them their minions if you think of it
why would people dress up every year and
go door to door to get candy
they're basically making us hide our
identity under costumes pumpkins are
also a part of this i don't understand
this it's just a way of controlling
little people's children i don't know so
if you just go with it okay pumpkins are
also part of this conspiracy we are
stabbing the poor squash and ripping its
delicate internal organs out and we also
end it all by carving a face into it
it sounds like a medieval horror film
the pumpkins are alive
now i hope i can spread awareness of
this theory and make people more
cautious before letting children fall
into this cycle who is this right good
evening and goodbye assistant this makes
absolutely no sense i think it makes a
lot of sense it makes no sense it's
basically saying that you're letting
the government control kids eating candy
and dressing up and they're all doing
the same thing and
i don't know it's just a control of the
masses okay that's a
government-controlled thing it's pretty
nice like i mean i have a halloween i
have another one that one didn't hit i
have another one yeah there was a tick
tock that went viral
um it had over 3 million likes or
something like that
so tesla's have this feature like a
person and car detection system
so i don't really know much about it i
don't have a tesla but i've seen on
their screen when you're driving yeah
you can see all the drivers nearby and
and little bodies and things like that
so there's i know exactly what you're
talking about right there was a clip
that this driver had his camera pointed
and he was going through a cemetery
and there were no cars around there are
no people around but there were
um
individuals walking
on the sensor that came out that weren't
in the sensor that weren't actually
there
yeah yeah so then they think that teslas
can see ghosts exactly so actually i did
some recon into it and this guy but he
also could claim this could be a total
lie but he said that he worked on tesla
and he said that the sensors are super
strong and the car is actually detecting
a human anatomy from six feet under
oh now if anyone would like to let me
borrow their tesla and go to a cemetery
i would greatly appreciate it
how crazy is that that's actually kind
of insane i know
that's weird i mean i wouldn't want to
like drive by something else and i see
it can you touch it dead body you see
ghosts on your tesla screen
actually i can do no wrong that's
awesome i can do no problem
no that's insane i feel like i've seen i
i think what he's single now so
what does that have to do with me i'm
not interested
elon
she goes i'm not interested
wait uh for even though you're not a
football player i mean this is just for
sure
i could wear a tesla
she's like i have a space helmet at home
you know what's kind of crazy that i
just realized i don't think i've ever
fully watched halloweentown
i just realized that you know that movie
that every single person in their mother
has watched
yeah i'm not a fan i don't like it
i don't know if it's on popular opinion
i don't like it i'll watch the holiday
during christmas like 800 times i won't
watch halloween time do you remember um
monster house
that cartoon yeah that gave me
nightmares you know what gave me
nightmares and you know exactly what i'm
talking about that anime fabric oh
no that anime uh not spirit away it's um
screw it away it's no
almost killed our skeleton we actually
just bought a skeleton for the house you
guys i was supposed to bring him i'm
sorry his name is norm he's a skeleton
rat we got him at the
store that's going to be our one
decoration in our apartment i think it
should be our house but he is our
hospital he's never going to like go
away
he's really cute but um none of our
friends really like him he's cute should
we do our unsolicited advice absolutely
so you guys remember if you want to get
your question answered to unsolicited
advice you have to go to the apple
podcast give us a five star and write
your questions there this is from it's
fate
b
yeah yeah it's question from faith oh
faith okay hey girls love the podcast do
you guys have any advice on staying
disciplined
i feel like myself and a lot of people
struggle with this especially with
college workouts etc also any skincare
favorites love you both thank you for
writing in faith yeah that is a good
question actually any advice of staying
disciplined
i feel like in school when it came to
homework and studying i was a very
disciplined kid because i had to be but
whenever it comes to
things that tasks i do for myself i'm
very lazy yeah i'll put it off you know
it's kind of interesting because you
when i always say this when i went from
college and even when you go from high
school to now just in the real world and
you kind of have to start getting a
routine from yourself it can be really
hard especially i mean we're we're
self-employed basically and so a lot of
the things that we have to do we have to
do it ourselves and so to stay
disciplined it takes a lot of planning
and organizing and the ways that we do
it because i think we've gone slightly
better at it i'm not saying we're
perfect we have different techniques as
well yeah for me i'd say with like
working out and uh even if i was doing
work i have to put it down on my
calendar like with workouts i have to do
workout classes because i won't go to
the gym unless someone like forces me to
or if i have a teacher telling me what
to do so sometimes if you book things in
advance and or find some deals where you
can just like go every single week yeah
that helps just to get out of the house
yeah i get consistently i don't go to
workout classes so if you're like me and
you just are going to the gym but it's
really hard to motivate yourself to
actually get up and do it yourself i
write down everything so every single
day i'll write in my notepad everything
that i want to get done whether it's a
big task or a small task something from
call my mom back to
go work out for 25 minutes because at
least you did that
do 30 minutes of your essay right now if
you just write down everything and then
crossing it off your list feels so good
i think stay away from your computer or
your phone writing things down i do it
for my phone and computer just so in
case i don't have my notebook with me i
just know what's going on but i highly
recommend you invest in getting just a
planner and something that's a little
bit bigger writing it down because
honestly you realize the amount of
things you have to do isn't that
daunting i think when you think that
there's so much going on it seems a lot
more overwhelming totally and then you
don't get through anything because
you're kind of paralyzed there and so
definitely writing it down definitely
having a schedule and having a goal to
reach yeah isn't too far in advance
because say if i i mean we just had this
the other day we were in london kind of
going off
and eating poorly and we're like okay we
want to stay disciplined and eating well
so we're like okay there's something to
look forward to exactly so having goals
for sure if you're like i want to reach
this gpa by the end of the semester like
just something that isn't so long term
that it seems
it's going to be forever to obtain
i think that's really important too i
hope that helped yeah but she also has
for good skincare oh yes i've been very
into skincare lately because i have
struggled with terrible skin growing up
i had um what is called keratosis
polarity she had it on her face though
so that's different yeah so
basically if you don't know what that is
it's sort of the it looks like they call
chicken skin and it's like a red rash
that you see on people's arms and it's
really rare to get on your face but
lucky me when i was growing up i was the
rare case that got it all over her face
so all of middle school and all of high
school i had it really bad and so i
never understood a good skincare i never
understood good makeup what reacted it
so what i like to do is i just bought
this hyaluronic acid i think it's from
the ordinary
and
it's only like eight dollars it's
incredible that has changed my skincare
game a hundred percent i just started
using
a
argan oil for my face like a drop that
really helps at night
um and i'm very bougie i use the jade
roller i don't think it actually does
anything but it makes me feel like
a better person yeah and for me i
i i used to do this too much where i
would over complicate my skincare and i
do way too many products because i
thought that's what you had to do like a
toner this this so this is this and then
it became like overreacting and i
learned somewhere
just don't wash your face a hundred
times a day just wash it at night after
all your makeup like scrub your face off
get it all done in the morning just
cleanse with water and just put on a
moisturizer or like a vitamin c serum
like those yeah
less is more so that's my biggest
suggestion and actually i love my
vitamin c that i got it's true see and i
got on amazon there's like 60 000
reviews on it so it's definitely popular
and it works
we've definitely been really into
skincare because our mom yeah has had a
skincare company her whole life so when
you're growing up my mom was like
clearing all of our volleyball team's
acne like she just so we definitely have
got it down but it's something that she
which the biggest advice she told me was
what you said but less is more
especially when it comes to makeup don't
put so much makeup on but here i am with
so much so much makeup on giving no
don't take my advice yeah but yeah
buying also the foundation that doesn't
make you break out because that changed
everything i do think if you're going to
invest in anything makeup wise that's
pricey it'd be your foundation but
i used to use a very expensive
foundation the giorgio armani and that
gave me a rash well it's if you're if
you're researching the right one because
i had a lot of oils but i'll tell i'm
gonna put you guys on one i just started
using the covergirl i got it on rite aid
uh
what is it it has um i think coconut
water in it and it's in a pink tube
use it it's amazing try it
it's a foundation mm-hmm wow that's so
good i gotta get that because i wanna
see a lot of things that i have i've
gone from her yeah i'm a fan she's a
really good at like research you know a
lot of people i get a lot of i'm good at
zodiac she's gonna makeup
i get a lot of comments saying that i
should do a makeup routine you should
and i should do a hair but that
terrifies me oh i'm bad at it i did it
one time and i'm telling you i looked
horrible remember that video i tried to
make it was cute
why didn't you like it because my
contour looked like i was oh yeah makeup
no yeah yeah no no
i think i'm not bad at makeup my god i'm
good at my own i'm bad at everyone
else's so don't let me do your makeup
but i can show you what i do and that's
that but thank you faith for writing in
and if you guys have any other questions
definitely go to apple podcast and ask
your question there and you guys have
been really great by the way like we've
been getting so many responses since
this new studio and everything and you
guys have been the best and we're going
to keep trying to talk about serious
topics girl chats all that stuff in
between because i know you guys are
saying that you like the balance between
that so season two has been awesome
really fun so really i don't think i
understand i wake up every morning and i
read all of the comments every single
one and i would have to say most of them
are really nice well yeah i'm actually
very shocked
99 are like super great so thank you
guys for writing and supporting and also
keep posting on your story that you're
listening because we will repost every
single one of them and it makes us so
elated didn't someone oh we didn't even
mention this someone in london
approached us saying that their little
sister that goes to boarding school all
of her girlfriends sit around and listen
to it during lunch let me tell you
if you guys are listening
i'll be very specific to the details of
this girl if you're listening at
boarding school with your friends and
you're not allowed to have your phone
right now and you're being secretive at
lunch time listening to our podcast we
freaking love you girls thank you for
just doing it thank you for sneaking
your phone and impossibly getting in
trouble and thank you to the sister that
approached us and let us know every time
you guys do that we are honestly shocked
and honestly it makes us look a lot
cooler in front of us every time we're
getting approached every time
this is so crazy every single time that
someone has come up to us on the street
about the podcast it's been in front of
one or both of our parents do you
understand how much credibility we get
after that our parents are like wait
finally the rules were burst yeah
literally like people won't approach our
parents they'll come to us and go we
love your episodes i'm like sippy and i
think with like we literally feel so
good after honestly i feel like we i'm
not saying we've made it no
not but i spent three times no no no no
but every time it happens i'm like okay
like
we're like that's worth it it's worth it
so thank you guys we're really excited
for halloween to come up so guys send us
all your halloween
stories what happens after this next
weekend i feel like we're going to come
back with a lot of stuff oh you know
we'll come back the last time let's just
say your girl is going on a bender
that's
that's great and i'll be right along
with her i'll be in flavor town and i'll
be on the football team put me in coach
thank you guys so much and we'll see you
guys next week
[Music]